my name is Mei my question is how big is
face
hi Mei so you asked how big a space how
big is the universe well we don't truly
know what we know is that the space that
we can observe which is really the only
thing we can sensibly talk about is
about thirteen point five billion
light-years in size and and that radius
that size of the universe is getting
bigger and bigger every day and that's
consistent that's based on our
understanding that the universe started
out in the very small region that has
been expanding initially very rapidly
and steadily now for billions of years
and we have only had there for thirteen
and a half billion years to wait to
accumulate light from distant parts of
the universe so we can only see as far
as light could have traveled in thirteen
point five billion years the universe is
continuing to expand in fact it seems to
have an accelerated expansion so a
billion years from now we will have be
we will be able to see out the distances
of fourteen and a half billion light
years away for all we know that
expansion could continue forever and the
size of the universe that we can observe
will grow indefinitely and therefore in
some sense the visible universe
ultimately will be arbitrarily big or
infinite in size it's conceivable there
are mathematically that that expansion
will stop and we will at some point not
the universe will
stop expanding and we'll be a well we
would what we call technically a closed
universe in which which would be finite
in size but the indications at the
moment are that that's not the case and
that it is infinite that doesn't mean
that it is at the moment we can see
infinitely far away we can't because it
takes a finite amount of time for light
to get here and we've only had thirteen
point five billion years or so since the
beginning whatever that is and we don't
understand it for light to propagate to
us